ukrainian president zielinski is
refusing to back down vowing to stay in
keeve despite the russian military's
vicious attack on his country and hit
squads trying to hunt him down zielinski
revealing his location in the war-torn
capital of kiev and sending this defiant
message
yes
dude
i stay here in kiev at bankova street i
don't hide and i'm not afraid of anyone
i will stay here as long as it's
necessary to win in our patriotic war
and as president zielinski begs the west
for more help poland today announcing it
is prepared to deploy mig-29 fighter
jets to a u.s and nato air base in
germany giving america the option to
transfer those aircraft to ukraine the
state department says it was caught off
guard so let's go to mike tobin he's and
leave ukraine with the latest there good
evening mike i think it's just after
midnight there
it is and uh poland was reluctant to
make this move uh fearing that slippery
slope to uh combat of east versus west
if they were to donate the aircraft and
suddenly there came this announcement
today that poland would donate its fleet
of mig-29s with the promise that the u.s
would backfill them with f-16s the
problem with it is u.s officials say
they were blindsided by this
announcement here's the under secretary
of state
when i saw that announcement by the
government of poland as i was literally
uh driving here today um
to my knowledge it wasn't pre-consulted
with us that they plan to
uh give these planes to us but as you
know we have been having consultations
with them for a couple of days now
about uh this request from the
ukrainians to receive their aircraft
now the ukrainians would welcome this
development because their pilots are
trained to fly uh the migs and this
seems to be a mechanism through which
the the polish government
can put it back on nato by putting the
planes back into uh back into the
ramstein air force base
but again the ukrainians have requested
time and time again for a no-fly zone or
the way the ukrainians put it to close
the sky they feel it would very it would
be a step toward equalizing this fight
in fact one of the refugees that i spoke
with yesterday said they very much want
to close the skies because if you can
take the fight to the ground he said we
kill them like rats guys back to you
right mike tobin thank you stay safe and
we'll see you later tonight i'm sure
jesse what do you think about this move
by the the polls holes really tried to
force our hand didn't they that was
came out of nowhere
uh i don't think the polls want their
hands dirty but do we want our hands
dirty why transfer the jets to ramstein
that's a u.s air base technically in
germany
i it seems convoluted to me but again
this is europe again trying to drag the
united states into a land war
potentially
in europe where they should be the ones
taking the lead this is a nato alliance
it's a defensive alliance let's not
expand it and play a game of chicken
with someone who has nothing to lose
putin has nothing to lose his economy is
cratering
this is his last gasp here this is all
or nothing for him and i don't why would
you play
chicken with someone like that he's just
going to go all out so it's incredibly
risky i'd like to just be a little more
measured you know we give them things
here we give them things there we kind
of ramp up see how russia reacts because
if we just start sending aircraft into
that war zone
i mean what happens if that pilot
engages a russian anti-aircraft uh
battalion down on the ground so we're
taking out russia
aircraft batteries in russia proper or
belarus i mean that's how you have to
defend yourself in the sky
i'm just afraid of this thing spiraling
out of control we have gone
the entire cold war with never having to
get involved with a shooting war with
the russians and then now all of a
sudden we're going to escalate right on
their front door
i mean i like the idea this is a proxy
we're now right we're at proxy war and
we're doing it right on their doorstep i
get it that's where we are now
uh but
the jet thing seems a little risky and
i'm not i'm not ready to say hey biden
you're a commander-in-chief you're in
charge i trust you this is not a guy i
trust to manage this type of delicate
deal with the russians who are desperate
right now well the other thing is
earlier today we were told that there
was frustration that there that this
decision-making was stuck at the white
house and we asked admiral kirby about
that he's like oh no no no everything's
fine i think well clearly everything was
not fine geraldo if the polls decided
like okay we will force your hand and
send these to ramstein
you know i i think that the
whole idea of it in in theory is is fine
and noble and uh it sounds like it would
be effective and then and it would
answer our nagging uh you know
gut-wrenching uh feeling that we're
allowing the ukrainians to be pummeled
from the air uh by the rush uh russians
air superiority but i i don't see it
happening mechanically it's uh what do
you do you send the ukrainian pilots to
to germany uh then you've got to check
them out you've got to make sure that
they can integrate the polish
instrumentation with the the ukrainian
air defenses happened in world war ii
it's i i think that in world war ii and
len lee's it happened but it took a long
time and europe is still mad at us for
taking so long to get to get involved to
get engaged i like the idea in theory i
just don't see it i agree with jesse
about the need to be measured and not
provoke
you know a wounded lion there one quick
thing about zielinski and his safety i
think zielinski is already immortal he's
already leonidas he's already churchill
they can't kill zielinski even if they
kill him he will he will live on forever
now i want i i don't want to be reckless
and i think that he uh again he's poking
uh putin maybe unnecessarily he has made
his point he uh you know he's a very
flamboyant in it and now i want him to
uh to keep keep trucking what about you
judge you've got got a
pensive look on your face yeah you know
i i have to tell you the us has always
taken the lead with nato
and i think you know that this is very
complicated but i also think that if
poland is willing to give you know the
migs to the ukrainians and that our job
would be to backfill
what is the problem and you mentioned at
geraldo and i throw this out for
discussion only with a ukrainian
getting that plane uh from poland or
from germany and flying it i mean these
people were watching the massacre of a
nation and children be this is this is
cannibalism what's going on there it's
terrorist i agree with that
this is medieval
and so we should well we got to make
sure they know how to fly the plane
baloney let them if we can get the
planes to them and make no mistake putin
is going to change the rules at every
turn if you provide a plane you're
provoking us if you do this you're
provoking me at some point we've got to
stand up and say we're stronger than you
are you little what what if he fires a
tactical nuclear weapon well that's the
problem that's a problem and what if we
what if we like kowtow and so he's got
no incentive to not do it and say we're
not even gonna we're not even gonna do
our nuclear exercises because we don't
want to intimidate him
not the wrong guy in the white house
lots of choose from there yeah uh i'm
you know with i think that the the over
arching message is we should be very
wary of being pulled into anything based
on narratives coming out of ukraine or
russia uh there's a lot of stuff that we
hear about that turns out not to be true
the media is framing this in a way that
is and this isn't my analogy but this is
the way i feel that ukraine is like the
child of a divorce
and they're fighting for custody and
russia is the biological parent and we
are the stepmom who doesn't want the
abusive dad to get him that may not be
an accurate analogy but that's how i
feel the narrative dynamic is going and
i see this is what i give credit to
zielinski
is that this is the old world versus the
new world putin thinks the world is only
about seizing land but zielinski
understands in the world of connect
connectivity you're seizing minds now
he's fighting a persuasive battle for
mines and he's kicking putin's butt on
this whether the stuff that zielinski is
saying is actually true it's positively
trumpian what zelinski's doing i love
zelinski the way a chicken loves the guy
who feeds him pellets because i'm in an
industry where i love getting that
pellet every day and learning what i'm
going to say but you have to wonder when
you're listening to this stuff and
whether these pellets are real or not
whether we are being artificially pulled
into a conflict right through this david
and goliath narrative that we're being
given but it's true well maybe it is
yeah it is
is this true maybe it is i'm not saying
it's not true but i'm saying you have to
be aware of what's true versus what
stands out everyday plans planes leave
every second of the day we the only
thing that stands out is when a plane
crashes so we like the stuff that stands
out to be reported but it's not
necessarily representative of reality we
have to ask ourselves every day are we
being manipulated into entering a war
that we should be no part of and i
resent anybody saying oh you must be
pro-russia or po-poon no i'm just
pro-america but you gotta you can't deny
your eyes though you can't i understand
that are you getting involved then i i
think i i
what i argue is getting involved as far
as we can get involved
giving them everything they possibly
need that we have
up until like the javelins the stingers
yeah uh the uh the the the other of the
shoulder-fired missiles we knocking
helicopters and aircraft the russians
out of the sky if if the story is true
that david is now mustering his strength
and is taking on this goliath
effectively and the convoy is still
stalled and weapons are being uh you
know tanks abandoned and crews uh
surrendering you know
it could happen that it's a happy ending
i hope so hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else